bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous
regarde en direct sur avis vous
retrouvez au sommaire ce soir l'un des
nombreux signes de la montée de la
violence dans le pays les actes
antireligieux dix ans après l'attentât
de mohamed merah à toulouse une mission
parlementaire dresse un constat
inquiétant qui touchait à tous les
cultes agressions antisémites violences
anti musulmanes profanées profanations
d'églises les faits sont de plus en plus
grave alors quel diagnostic au service
de quelles solutions on en parle dans un
instant avec nos invités dans notre
grand débat peut-on stopper le carnage
sans intervenir la pression monte sur
les occidentaux face au tournant de plus
en plus totalitaire du kremlin dont la
guerre en ukraine notre grand témoin ce
soir est un grand diplomatie l'a
rencontrée plusieurs fois vladimir
poutine sont lire le premier 21e siècle
paru il ya un an et à bien des égards
prémonitoire l'ancien secrétaire général
adjoint des nations unies jean marie
guéhenno est avec nous ce soir enfin j
-19 avant le premier tour dans le scan
ce soir le croisement des courbes entre
eric zemmour et jean luc mélenchon ce
sera dans l'oeil de blacko les deux
visages de marine le pen avec jean rémi
baudot et puis des affiches et slogans
de campagne au crible de géraldine
muhlmann voilà vous savez tout c'est
parti on est
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au rendez
vous 10 en dix ans après les attentats
de mohamed merah la france n'en a pas
fini avec la haine
l'antisémitisme s'est largement banalisé
dans le pays les actes anti-musulmans
grimpe en flèche et les catholiques
aussi sont pris pour cible bonsoir
isabelle florennes soir merci d'être là
vous êtes député modem des
hauts-de-seine et auteur avec votre
collègue ludovic mendes d'un rapport
remis au premier ministre jean castex
aujourd'hui même sur les actes anti
religieux vous nous dire exactement ce
que vous mettez derrière cette
appellation et quelles sont vos
propositions bonsoir chems eddine hafiz
et merci d'être là vous êtes le recteur
de la mosquée de paris n'en déplaise à
certains nous sommes les enfants de la
république c'est le titre de votre
dernier ouvrage paru chez quéro vous
vous battez au quotidien à la fois
contre toutes les formes de haine
l'antisémitisme contre l'islamisme aussi
vous mettez aussi contre les actes anti
musulmans vous nous expliquerez tout
cela au quotidien dans votre dans votre
mosquée vous battez aussi pour que la
liberté d'expression et la laïcité soit
respectée dans le pays bonsoir ianesco
d'air bienvenu professeur d'histoire
géographie en seine saint denis membre
du conseil des sages de la laïcité au
sein du ministère de l'éducation
nationale vous dirigez aussi
observatoire de l'éducation de la
fondation jean jaurès enfin bon soir et
dix pages laisse vous êtes secrétaire
général de l'adil crasse et la direction
interministériel à la lutte contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme et la haine anti
lgbt c'est sous la houlette de matignon
je deviens oui c'est bien ça alors on va
revenir bien sûr sur votre rapport dans
un instant sur des actes antireligieux
mais je voulais forcément qu'on s'arrête
d'abord sur ce temps de commémoration
toulouse emmanuel macron a rendu hommage
aux victimes de mohamed merah nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande étaient
invités aussi d'hier soir au bataclan
lieu symbolique s'il en est à prendre la
parole dans le cadre d'une soirée
organisée par le crif sujet signé marion
becker regarder
le bataclan scène meurtri par le
terrorisme lieu symbolique choisie par
le crif le conseil représentatif des
institutions juives de france pour
commémorer les dix ans des attentats de
toulouse et de montauban la france face
à l'antisémitisme et l'islamisme à la
tribune deux anciens chefs de l'état
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy ont
appelé à lutter sans relâche contre le
terrorisme
le mal ne s'explique pas il ce combat il
n'y a rien à expliquer ces des barbares
qui mènent la guerre et si nous on ne
peut pas la faire
selon la belle formule on aura la guerre
et le déshonneur les deux pour le prix
d'un et si on commence à dire ah ben il
faut rien faire contre d'âge contre les
organisations terroristes parce que on
pourrait éventuellement avoir une
réplique théorie alors nous sommes des
lâches il faut renoncer à toute ambition
pour notre pays dimanche déjà à toulouse
lors de la cérémonie en hommage aux
victimes de mohamed merah emmanuel
macron rappelait l'engagement de la
france dans cette lutte contre le
terrorisme depuis dix ans face au drame
face à leurs répétitions nous n'avons
pas baissé la tête
nous n'avons pas non plus baisser les
bras
nous n'avons rien céder rien abandonné
sur est fier de nos valeurs recherchant
sans trêve l' équilibre entre la défense
de nos libertés et le renforcement de
notre sécurité depuis 2012 et les
attaques de mohamed merah les attentats
ont fait 271 morts en france
[Musique]
c'est important cet attentat de mohamed
merah parce que on a tué on a tué des
juifs parce qu'ils étaient juifs on a
tué aussi des soldats parce qu'il
représentait la france trois soldats
tués ils étaient de confession musulmane
et puis après il ya eu 2015 la rédaction
de charlie décimée et puis le bataclan
et là on a tué tout le monde si je veux
dire 130 morts isabelle farrell on va
parler de votre rapport mais je voulais
commencer par ce temps de commémoration
est ce que vous avez le sentiment que
dix ans après on a tiré les leçons au
fond de ce nouveau ballon nouvelle forme
de terrorisme un terrorisme islamiste
qui frappe c'est une nouvelle vague qui
frappe le pays est ce que on a compris
et est-ce qu'on a agi on agit sans aucun
doute et le président l'a rappelé hier
et et les présidents successifs
agissent depuis de nombreuses années et
les résultats même si on peut se dire
que c'est 200 victimes sont des victimes
bien entendu qui ne devrait pas et qui
ne doit qui sont des morts de trop
évidemment pour notre pays on a aussi et
en particulier je crois à dire sous
cette mandature aussi
heureusement arrêté énormément de
personnes fait ce travail de prévention
renseignements mais qui est fondamental
c'est fondé la société est sorti d'une
forme de déni sur la montée de
l'islamisme vous le dire y est c'est ça
existe maintenant il va en parler que
c'est plus compliqué je parle des moyens
des moyens qui ont été donnés de
d'actions qui ont été faites c'est
peut-être plus compliqué au sein de la
société en tout cas on en reparlera avec
le rapport mais une partie en tout cas
de d de la communauté juive qu'on a eu
l'occasion de rencontrer entre autres
mais d autres cultes évidemment sont
très inquiet son très inquiet sur cette
société sur les violences quelles
qu'elles soient
sur les actes et sur surtout les propos
aussi
désinhibé de certains donc là dessus il
ya une lutte et je crois que toute la
société ansamble les cultes et et
l'éducation élargi il en a b c c'est là
que c'est un travail comme un affaire et
a continué à faire de cohésion de la
société autour de ces terroristes est
aussi de la gangrène finalement de
certains propos et de la propagation de
certains propos je tiens à dire
qu'effectivement il ya des choses
inquiétantes notamment sur cette
propagation sur les réseaux sociaux
cette haine en ligne qui vers
d'accélérateur dans l'est dans les zones
ans chems eddine hafiz à chaque attentat
islamiste
comment le musulman vous êtes réagi
écoutez d'abord je partage totalement ce
qui vient d'être dit en même temps
lorsque vous avez passé ce petit ce
passage où il ya donc deux anciens
présidents qui s'exprime le président
macron
moi je subis la double peine les
musulmans de france subissent une double
peine parce que en même temps ils sont
citoyens mais en même temps il est en
train de tuer au nom de notre religion
moi tous les matins quand je fais ma
prière je veux dire loghbar et
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une expression
guerrière c'est devenu une expression de
haine de mort et vous imaginez que les
musulmans de france aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement inquiet parce que
malheureusement les pointe souvent du
doigt ce terrorisme islamiste et nourine
l anti musulman bien sûr parce que
aujourd'hui dans ce pan les extrémismes
se nourrissent entre elles quand il ya
des candidats à la présidence de la
république qui aujourd'hui essentialise
les musulmans de france quand il parle
du grand remplacement quand il parle des
français de papier
évidemment parce que de l'autre côté
vous avez les extrémistes qui disent aux
jeunes musulmans il faut surtout pas
vous rapprocher de la citoyenneté
devenir citoyen parce que vous vous
éloignez de votre foi et donc on est
vraiment dans un dilemme est aujourd'hui
c'est pour cela qu'au mois de septembre
j'avais sorti ce
manifeste pour dire qu'il faut
absolument qu'il y ait une frontière
étanche entre l'islamisme et l'islam
l'islam n'est pas une religion de haine
de violence ou de guerre c'est
l'idéologie politique est aujourd'hui en
train de se genre de massacre donc il
faut aujourd'hui que les musulmans de
france qui sont des citoyens part
entière qui partagent je dirais la même
idée que la nation française de tous les
citoyens il faut aujourd'hui raison
garder ne pas faire cet amalgame
malheureusement ces faits souvent cette
distinction islam islamisme est ce que
vous l'expliquer régulièrement vos
élèves ce qu'il ya besoin d'expliquer
encore aujourd'hui il ya naturellement
besoin de l'expliquer il faut toujours
expliquer ces différences et en même
temps en écoutant en écoutant monsieur
je me disais que
il y a quand même chez les musulmans de
france une minorité et je dis bien une
minorité qui a du mal à condamner des
attentats qui a du mal à adhérer à
certaines valeurs de la république
française j'ai bien d'une minorité et de
fait
cette minorité qui a du mal à dire que
ce café mohamed merah et est évidemment
terrible que ce qui s'est passé au
bataclan est absolument horrible et bien
cette minorité elle nourrit aussi
parfois le discours d' amalgame que vous
dénoncez fort justement et donc il y à
là je crois quelque chose à faire en
termes d'éducation en termes de discours
dans les familles peut-être aussi dans
les mosquées qui doit minorité
précisément au fond sécessionnistes que
vous décrivez écoutez moi je me base
d'abord sur les nombreux les nombreuses
enquêtes ont été faites notamment par la
fondation jean jaurès 1 sur ces
questions-là sur les travaux de bernard
rougier les territoires conquis de
l'islamisme nous savons aujourd'hui
qu'il y à une minorité encore j'insiste
sur ce terme minorité voilà qui a du mal
à
à reconnaître ou plutôt à adhérer tout
simplement à ce qu'est cette pas ce que
sont ces valeurs de la république
française et de ce fait il a tout ce
travail d'éducation à faire enfin les
pêcherait justement peut-être
l'amalgamme que vous dénoncez fort
justement j'espère terminer ce tour de
table vous dirais que aujourd'hui
l'islamisme est la principale cause de
l'antisémitisme dans notre pays où c'est
plus compliqué que ça ya encore un bon
vieil antisémitisme issue des années 30
voilà qui qui continue de gronder pas
sans doute avons nous tous
collectivement mis trop de temps à
reconnaître que l'antisémitisme venait
également de personnes qui étaient
potentiellement victimes de racisme
des gens qui sont radicalisées mais pas
seulement probablement cette minorité
dont parlait yanis robert voilà on le
voit très rapidement à vous parliez des
juifs qui étaient tués parce que je vis
ça a été le cas dylan halimi notamment
il ya de cela 16 ans maintenant c'était
devant les jeunes de banlieue issus de
l'immigration qui était pas des jeunes
radicalisé mais qui était voilà qui
propageaient ces préjugés ancestraux et
là on avait vraiment un cas de figure
d'islamistes indiens c'est vraiment des
plus récents et strauss selon lesquelles
des juifs ont de l'argent et ça c'est
vraiment des préjugés qui viennent aussi
de l'extrême droite et qu'elle est
vraiment qui vient de très très loin
donc ça il a fallu le dénoncer et on
voit bien d'ailleurs voilà le fait qu'il
puisse y avoir et c'est pour ça que
c'est important d'avoir adopté la
définition de l'antisémitisme de 2 lié à
chara qui parle des différentes formes
d'antisémitisme
parce que lorsque on fait l'amalgamé
notamment avec les anti vaccins et que
les persécutions qui a pu avoir et les
discriminations qui a pu avoir pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale à l'égard des
juifs en disant que c'est des mêmes
sortes de souffrances aujourd'hui en
oubliant l'extermination des juifs ça
n'est pas la même chose que lorsque on
va s'en prendre aux juifs parce que on
diabolise israël et qui a une forme de
haine d'israël qui en réalité dissimule
une haine des juifs et c'est important
pour bien combattre l'antisémitisme de
bien savoir le reconnaître il peut
s'exprimer dans diverses parties de la
population quand on a vu des personnes
qui arboraient des toiles jaune cet été
pendant les manifestations les anti
vaccins ce n'était pas du tout des
personnes issues de l'immigration ne
pouvait y en avoir mais c'était pas ça
le sujet c'était souvent des créations
issu de l'extrême droite donc cet
antisémitisme il s'exprime un peu
partout dans la société mais il a
plusieurs visages et plusieurs causes
alors on va pas s'arrêter uniquement sur
l'antisémitisme même si vous allez nous
le dira c'est évidemment les chiffres
sont très inquiétants vous appelez ça
les actes anti religieux isabelle
florennes nous avons suivi votre mission
parlementaire c'est un reportage
d'hélène bonduelle avec gilles lepeytre
au regard des
quartiers de la petite jérusalem à
sarcelles la plus grande communauté
juive d'europe vite ici et elle est
encore traumatisé par une vague de
violence antisémite il y a huit ans
aujourd'hui on est en 2022 huit ans plus
tard les gens s'en souviennent comme si
c'était les gens étaient vraiment
agressé violenté façon vous savez c'est
assez cyclique ça va ça vient ça va il
suffit qu'ils aient une information qui
partent d'israël et puis ça y est tout
peut s'embraser c'est ce type de
témoignage que ludovic mendes et
isabelle florennes vienne collectés l'an
dernier
1659 actes antireligieux ont été
recensés dont 589 antisémite
on a le premier code et
alors il a fallu sécuriser les
synagogues ici deux codes des caméras de
surveillance et des vitres blindées
mamie ce qu'on appelle ici du br si
c'est à dire un carreau qui est
extrêmement large et qui est anti
déflagration aurait imaginé dans la rue
regarder toutes les voitures qu'un donc
après ce qu'on a vu et ce qu'on a connu
en france on est on est une cible
incroyable plus de cent cinquante mille
euros de travaux ont été engagés tous
financés par le fonds interministériel
pour la prévention de la délinquance il
est de plus en plus sollicité par les
communautés religieuses
le père du mathieu a longtemps officié
en milieu rural et pour éviter les actes
de vandalisme
ils n'avaient souvent qu'une solution
dans les petits villages on peut pas se
permettre de laisser des églises
ouvertes elle se ferait elle se ferait
payer tout simplement il ya des belles
choses dans nos églises donc aujourd'hui
la majorité des églises sont fermés mais
la majorité des lieux de culte hormis
les bas de sécurité de vols de
dégradations de risque d'incendié de
sécurité globale alors en arrivant à
sarcelles le curé a pris les devants
j'aime y est quand même depuis quelques
temps une petite caméra à leur niveau de
la delà de l'église saint jean xxiii
857 actes antichrétiens ont été
comptabilisés l'an dernier des chiffres
souvent minorés car beaucoup de fidèles
ne porte pas plainte le savoir est ce
qu'on est chrétiens le on à dire bon
c'est pas grave on pardonne et c'est là
on peut pardonner mais on peut aussi
rendre justice ça ça ça peut aller
ensemble ça doit aller ensemble
les actes anti musulmans eux ont
augmenté de près de 40 % en deux ans
et face aux députés ces imams évoque
surtout une stigmatisation des musulmans
il ressent comme quoi qu on est injuste
avec lui par rapport de considération et
par reprendre la vision qu'on évoquait
les parts dans les médias le fait de
parler toujours des musulmans en général
dans les médias par le politique n'aide
pas on a eu une ou même des
problématiques avec la loi soit
séparatisme sudiste séparatiste voir que
conforter les principes républicains à
lui apporter beaucoup de malentendus
donc il a fallu aussi beaucoup dominé
tous les cultes parle d'ailleurs d'une
montée de la haine sur les réseaux
sociaux une haine qui pour les deux
députés participent de la banalisation
de ces actes antireligieux
florennes vous avez choisi de traiter
les actes antireligieux si je veux dire
ensemble pourquoi ce choix ou on a vu
évidemment avec le premier sujet que
l'antisémitisme c'est un peu à part
parce que aujourd'hui au dessus des
juifs parce qu'ils sont juifs dans notre
pays est un peu différent est ce que
vous en convenez avec les autres cultes
et pourquoi volontairement mettre sous
une même ombrelle les trois cultes qui
sont on le comprend très bien avec ce
sujet cibler tous avec des degrés divers
alors on n'a pas vraiment choisi cette
mission est une mission ministérielle
qui vient du premier ministre avec une
attention du président de la république
sur un phénomène qui n'est pas nouveau
mais qui récemment a fait l'objet
d'augmentation vous les avez rappelé
vous avez rappelé les chiffres il 659
actes recensés en 2021 ça fait quasiment
cinq actes par jour c'est pas rien avec
des augmentations avec des inquiétudes
et un rapport si vous voulez de la part
du premier ministre des services
ministériels qui se sont dit on n'a
jamais fait état des lieux sur
l'intérieur
non ces mini salle intérieur
avec services territoriaux de
renseignement territoriales qui recense
ces actes donc l'objet de cette mission
c'est pour une première fois de faire
déjà un état des lieux puisqu'ils sont
inégalement répartis sur le territoire
français vous le dis vous disais
qu'est-ce que ça recouvre ça recouvre
effectivement des actes antichrétiens
parce que il ya quarante-cinq mille
églises en france et alors pas que des
lieux cultes ça peut être des insultes
sale et des violences c'est de la
violence sur les personnes c'est de la
profanation de cimetière c'est du
vandalisme dans des églises c'est
évidemment sur les mosquées ce même
genre d'actes ou des atteintes au culte
directement et aux personnes et pour la
communauté juive qui fait partie des
cultes monothéistes qu'on a évidemment
auditionné de façon très large
évidemment une antériorité par rapport à
cette montée de la violence du fait du
terrorisme comme on l'a rappelé dans la
première partie est donc une
organisation qui est très précieuse
malheureusement du fait de cette montée
de la violence ancienne depuis une
vingtaine d'années les concernant une
très bonne organisation du côté de la
communauté juive en termes de prévention
et de sécurisation comme on le voit
d'ailleurs d'un portage wii magog on
essaie
ça se développe maintenant pour
l'ensemble des cubes il s'agissait pour
nous de faire un état des lieux de voir
ce qui allait skier à laquelle étaient
les bonnes pratiques puisque nous avons
fait cinq déplacements en france nous
sommes allés à strasbourg à lyon à
toulon à nantes et à sarcelles vous nous
avez suivi c'était aussi très intense
très important de montrer les bonnes
pratiques parce qu'il ya une bonne
pratique du terrain de faire des
préconisations l'avenir dira pas ce
choix dit il ya déjà beaucoup de textes
de loi c'est pas grave qu'on veut un
voilà on veut pas noir non non je sais
bien vous êtes les sénateurs l'idée
série will est de faire bouger la
société aussi en y appliquant lieu vers
18 heures derrière vous allez nous dire
et des fourmis ne peut être appliqué sur
le terrain on imagine que l'éducation
est lé centrale sur ces sujets là
monsieur le recteur les actes
anti-musulmans augmente
en deux ans de 40%
complètement qu'est ce que vous vous
constatez écouter on constate
effectivement que aujourd'hui
quel que soit le culte hindou dre dirait
préciser parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à vouloir séparer mais moi je
pense que lorsqu'on annonçait la bonne
approche quand on s'attaque à des juifs
ou à des chrétiens ou wade musulman moi
je pense que c'est à peu près la même
chose on l'a dit souvent lorsqu'on
s'attaque à un musulman derrière on
s'attaque à un juif on s'attaque à un
chrétien de et moi j'ai trouvé que
l'idée de 2,7 de cette mission était
intéressante puisque on mettait tous les
cultes sur un piédestal qu'il fallait
après examiner quelle égalité voulait
dire oui pardon et donc toute cette
situation il faut absolument la regarder
les musulmans sont inquiets comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure on subit la
double peine et de l'autre côté les les
lieux de culte musulmans sont souvent
attaqués alors ce ne sont pas des
attaques d'une violence extrême il n'est
pas encore une mort d'homme vous
reconnaissez qu'il ya des degrés de
violence la misère différents
scientifiques allemands motion moi je ne
compare pas l'incomparable de toutes les
manières alors tout à l'heure vous avez
dit que les que les juifs étaient les
plus touchés mais enfin les catholiques
aussi entre le permet les puits là la
basilique de nice où il ya eu un
sacristain et de deux femmes qui ont été
tués à l'intérieur de l'église moi je
trouve ça totalement horrible et il
faudrait pas si vous voulez aujourd'hui
parce que c'est mon de stigmatisation il
revient sans cesse dans la bouche de
certains musulmans pas tous un français
de confession musulmane qu'est ce qu'il
recouvre qu'est ce qu'on vit contourner
ce sens on attendait d'abord la
cimentation la cible la stigmatisation a
été effectivement très utilisé pourquoi
parce que certaines tendances
extrémistes de l'islam essaye en tout
état de cause de séparer la communauté
musulmane du reste de la communauté
nationale ça c'est une des jeux d'hier
aidée à un des objectifs majeurs des
islamistes aujourd'hui essayer
d'extirper cette composante musulmane de
france 2 du reste de la communauté
nationale est ce assez pour nous
franchement insupportable
nous sommes des citoyens à part entière
on s'en rend compte à chaque fois qu'on
s'adresse à quelqu'un je suis avocat
partir du moment je dis que je suis
musulman je suis désolé mais tu vas
travail décent d'une case parce qu'on me
regarde on oublie que je suis avocat
mais on se rappelle que je suis musulman
et ça c'est dans tous les actes de la
vie quotidienne et donc comme je le
disais tout à l'heure les extrêmes se
nourrissent vraiment de façon tout à
fait naturelle et les discours qu'y sont
tenues aujourd'hui sur le plan politique
moi je veux dénoncer ce livre là a été
fait à bon escient pour parler pendant
la campagne je trouve totalement
insupportable cette situation où on est
constamment en train de d'essentialiser
les musulmans alors tout à l'heure on a
parlé de cet extrait mis de cette
minorité musulmane mais moi je la
considère pas parce que il faut faire la
conque la différence entre et l'islam
qui est une religion la sphère ilan
halimi vous avez raison ce ne sont pas
ce sont des immigrés mais ce qu ils
l'ont fait au nom de l'islam est ce que
ce sont des musulmans qui sont attaqués
à des juifs ce sont des voyous qui ont
considéré parce qu'il y a plein de
personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils considèrent
que les juifs sont en vie c'est ce que
vous avez utilisé comme argument mais il
y a égalé d'un dîner ils ont connu des
personnes d'extrême droite traditionnel
polonais il y à il y a effectivement à
l'intérieur des mosquées moi je veux
faire le distinguo si vraiment on veut
aller dans le détail il y a également
dans certaines mosquées un antisémitisme
et ça il faut le combattre en permanence
c'est ça aussi il faut véritablement
éviter d'essentialiser quand on parle de
cette minorité vous avez raison ça hips
avril il peut avoir un prénom maghrébins
c'est ce que je veux dire c'est pas au
nom de l'islam qu'il commet cet acte
c'est un jeune qui n'a qu'à une
ignorance totale de sa religion mais qui
pratiquent effectivement une forme de
délinquance robert lavoie du terrain
vous savez ce qu'on dit il n'y a plus un
seul juif dans les écoles de seine saint
denis ça s'est répété répété par des
gens qui ont peur et puis parler les
chiffres alors c'est pas forcément
toujours toujours vrai qu est ce que
vous vous constatez de ces violences
antisémites et de ses actes anti
musulmans dans les mots dans les
attitudes est-ce que c'est du quotidien
ou est-ce que c'est beaucoup plus rare
dans les classes c'est difficile de vous
répondre
moi je ne je ne constate plus d'actes
antisémites puisque je n'ai plus
d'élèves juifs tout simplement ils sont
partis donc effectivement
c'est difficile de voir des actes
antisémites quand il n'ya plus d'élèves
juifs en revanche des propos antisémites
nous pouvons toujours en entendre
évidemment
par exemple c'est très classique les
juifs ont de l'argent quand on fait un
cours sur le 11 septembre c'est le
mossad qui a fait ça sont les israéliens
sont des choses très classique que tout
le monde connaît aujourd'hui voilà mais
je voudrais dire quelque chose s'il veut
s'il vous plaît
je comprends et c'est très intéressant
de traiter de traiter ces agressions
sous l'angle religieux mais
l'antisémitisme n'est pas une question
religieuse
l'antisémitisme c'est une question de
racisme et c'est une vieille
construction
une vieille construction dans l'histoire
qui a une spécificité n'ont pas plus
grave ou moins grave qu'une autre s'agit
pas des rares chizé mais je me demande
dans quelle mesure en je vais prendre le
contre-pied de ce que vous dites dans
quelle mesure finalement traité
d'antisémitisme sous un angle religieux
ce n'est pas finalement nous empêcher de
comprendre ce qu'il a de spécifique je
veux dire par là que quand le rabbin de
la synagogue de sarcelles parle
d'agression est-ce qu'il est agressé
parce qu'il prix d'une certaine manière
est ce qu'il est agressée s'il est
agressée est-ce qu'il est agressé parce
que il a un livre
monsieur particuliers ou est-ce qu'il a
un discours public particulier non il
est agressé par pour ce qu'il est voilà
intrinsèquement pour ce qu'il est donc
on est et c'est pour cela que la
délégation que don ellis jeunesse et la
secrétaire générale s'appelle délégation
à la lutte contre le contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas sur une question de luttes
religieuses ou de questions religieuses
on est sur une question de racisme et
c'est là quelque chose de différent
laisse vous êtes d'accord avec cette
distinction au fond qu'il faut toujours
répéter sur la spécificité de
l'antisémitisme une forme de
spécificités en effet que les juifs
peuvent avoir une pratique religieuse
ils peuvent ne pas en avoir c'est à dire
être juif mais au simplement leur
origine leur culture etc et être attaqué
de la même manière donc oui c'est une
spécificité et à l'adil cra on lutte
contre toutes les formes de racisme dans
la loi on parle pas de racisme on parle
pas d'antisémitisme on parle de d'attac
donc que ce soit des propos des menaces
ou des actes physiques à l'égard de
personnes en fonction de leur origine de
leur appartenance à une ethnie à une
race entre guillemets à leur religion et
c'est donc en réalité ces actes de haine
ils peuvent être entier religieux mais
il ne faut surtout pas tout mélanger
c'est à dire qu'il existe aussi et
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur les
recense des acteurs raciste qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la religion comment
vous travaillez concrètement on a bien
vu les différences de degré et même de
nature qu'est ce qu'on fait au fond
parce que c'est un un vaste chantier il
ya l'éducation il faut changer la
société il faut changer les mentalités
comment concrètement au delà des lois et
des sanctions du travail de la justice
comment on fait pour faire bouger ça
dans la société alors déjà on travaille
beaucoup sur l'éducation comme vous le
disiez la sensibilisation dès le plus
jeune âge aujourd'hui justement depuis
le 21 mars on est dans une semaine
d'éducation et d'action contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme qui multiplie
les initiatives partout sur le
territoire dans les établissements
scolaires mais partout dans les musées
les lieux de mémoire les collectivités
locales on travaille à la déconstruction
des préjugés la déconstruction des
préjudices importants que ça et préjugés
c'est on en a presque tous sens et une
espèce de culture populaire qui tient
pour vrai quelque chose qui n'est pas
démontré les moyens ou alors ça passe
vers binôme aimant d'associations
présents rares yémen notamment dans la
jeunesse en réalité ce qu'il faut c'est
justement s'interroger interrogé les
jeunes sur ce qu'il croit et puis
apprendre à se connaître à se parler et
donc c'est important en fonction des
quartiers d origine de favoriser le
dialogue et pour ça il ya des
associations mais ce qui est important
si c'est conforme les professeurs c'est
qui est des ressources pour les
professeurs parce qu'eux aussi sont
confrontés à des cas et qu'ils ne soient
pas isolés qu'ils ne soient pas démuni
donc c'est important jean michel
blanquer a créé ces équipes valeurs de
la république qui aide qui équipe un
petit peu les les professeurs sur le
terrain et puis il faut travailler aussi
à la sanction non conformes les
policiers tous les gendarmes tous les
policiers on forme les magistrats pour
qu'ils puissent connaître la loi et
l'appliquer c'est leur rôle de
l'appliquer aussi dans ce domaine là
c'est à dire d'accueillir les victimes
parce qu'on voit dans le rapport qu'il
ya un certain nombre de victimes qui ne
vont même pas porté plainte d'actualité
suivre prendre les pleins mais largement
donc été et que derrière lille et plus
de sanctions donc on voit que la loi
doit s'appeler leur un tour de table sur
chacun dans vos regardant dans vos
secteurs professionnels des solutions
des pistes de solution ou adam peut-être
même déjà appliquée ce qui existait à
bâle absolument donc juste pour répondre
enfin évidemment
l'antisémitisme ça va bien au delà de
simples actes antireligieux ça nous
devions le traité évidemment dans ce
rapport je suis d'accord avec vous que
c'est un phénomène bien plus large mais
dans les solutions dans nos
préconisations évidemment c'est pas une
loi ce que j'ai dit il ya déjà une
meilleure communication entre les
pouvoirs publics et les cultes a
renforcé un certain nombre de moyens de
communication il ya des choses très
intéressantes que nous avons découvert
notamment 205 référent qui
descrimination répartis sur l'ensemble
du territoire auprès des cours d'appel
pour le suivi justement est ce travail
de suivi des victimes qui est vraiment
nécessaire quand ça fonctionne c'est
très important pour chacun d'eux se rend
de se sentir d'abord écouté reconnu
parce que les enquêtes sont compliquées
quand il ya eu des atteintes quand il ya
eu des plaintes c'est important que ce
suivi soit bien fait nous avons
auditionné évidemment l'adil cra et nous
reconnaissons le travail formidable que
fait cette délégation interministérielle
nous souhaitons envoie renforcer les
moyens humains
en termes de formation sur l'ensemble du
territoire je crois que c'est un souhait
qui est partagée également par l'adil
cra et puis évidemment sur l'éducation à
l'interné la vie et je vous laisse la
parole mais qui est demandé par
l'ensemble des cultes c'est vraiment il
ya déjà énormément de travaux qui sont
faits maintenant je pense que nous
avions le devoir au saut dans cette
mission de le dire pour aller dans le
sens qui est porté par l'éducation
nationale sur ces sujets entre autres ça
m'aidait nafiz sur le voile à des
propositions notamment les du confiance
qu'il faut renforcer d'abord le dialogue
interreligieux rappelons quand même
trois religions monothéistes et il faut
aujourd'hui rappelé les points communs
moi personnellement en tant que musulman
je dis à tous les juifs que tous les
prophètes juifs sont cités dans le
courant moïse est le plus cité dans le
courant alors que le prophète de l'islam
il est cité simplement six fois ce sont
des éléments importants qu'il faut
rappeler mais en même temps non pas se
limiter à parler entre responsables mais
en même temps aller le plus loin
possible
vous aviez d'ailleurs sur ce plateau
avec les représentants des différentes
évidemment
partie
rôdeur vous qui travaillez à la fois au
ministère de l'éducation sur sur ces
outils pédagogiques sur la laïcité la
liberté d'expression tout est lié oui ce
que je crois moi c'est qu'il faut faire
aimer la république il faut faire aimer
la laïcité faire comprendre que la
laïcité c'est la possibilité de la
liberté et qui est offerte à tous les
enfants de france et donc la possibilité
de se dégager de tout les déterminismes
qui sont les nôtres c'est la possibilité
de l'émancipation de la vraie liberté
c'est cela qu'il faut faire comprendre
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu sur le
plateau d'el cp parler de ces sujets
graves en ces temps de commémoration dix
ans après les attentats de mohamed merah
merci à vous alors je dis ce jeudi
figurez-vous cela fera déjà un mois que
vladimir poutine a lancé l'armée russe
dans la guerre en ukraine chaque jour un
peu plus fait se confie une tragédie
humanitaire joe biden arrive en europe
avec le sommet extraordinaire de l'otan
à bruxelles et pour parler de cette
guerre est de 60 ses enjeux politiques
géopolitiques on va accueillir un invité
exceptionnel un grand diplomate jean
marie guéhenno ancien secrétaire général
adjoint de l'onu alors avant de
l'accueillir portrait en quelques
questions avec marco pommier regarder
si on vous invite jean marie guéhenno
c'est parce que vous êtes un spécialiste
des questions de défense et des
relations internationales
cela ne vous a pas échappé notre monde
est tournante est alors face aux crises
quelle doit être la place de la france
les candidats à la présidentielle eux
ont leur petite idée d'abord je
rétablirai l'indépendance de la france
car en vérité la france n'a pas de
position officielle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au delà de renforcer notre souveraineté
européenne
notre souveraineté nationale à travers
l'europe je pense qu'il faut une union
franco allemand jean marie guénois où
vous êtes diplomate ancien secrétaire
général adjoint de l'onu mais aussi
professeur à l'université columbia de
new york dans vos livres vous analysez
la crise des démocraties loin du
triomphalisme de 1989 après la chute du
mur de berlin vous identifiez notre
péché originel
l'illusion de la victoire du camp
occidental face à l'union soviétique
on a compris pour le trion de la
démocratie ce qui était seulement en
fait que l'effondrement d'un système
épuisé l'union soviétique pendant la
guerre froide au fond la veille dans une
identité facile on avait un ennemi
aujourd'hui borné dans des société
émiettée on est dans ces sociétés qui se
déchire parce que au fond on n'a pas de
fondations pas de fondation à vous lire
la démocratie serait même un champs de
décombres alors jean marie guéhenno
notre modèle démocratique est il voué à
disparaître avec vous nous voulons aussi
comprendre le face à face tendu qui se
joue entre la chine et les états unis
d'après vole empire du milieu est un
adversaire stratégique pour les
américains mais vous ne croyez pas à une
nouvelle guerre froide entre ces deux
puissances
la différence entre la guerre froide à
l'union soviétique et la guerre froide
avec la chine c'est qu'entre union
soviétique et occident il y avait très
peu d'échangés konami aujourd'hui la
chine est le premier partenaire
économique de beaucoup de pays
occidentaux
mais que faire quand les rivalités
laisse place à la guerre quand la russie
cherche à retrouver son rang d'autrefois
trois semaines après le début de
l'invasion en ukraine vladimir poutine
at-il sous-estimé le patriotisme des
ukrainiens et quid de l'europe dans tout
cela vous qui affirmez qu'on ne peut se
passer d'elle entre la chine et les
états unis l'union européenne peut-elle
constituer une troisième voie monsieur
le diplomate nous attendons vos réponses
bonsoir jean marie guénois merci
infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on va tenter de
répondre à ces questions et de tirer les
premières leçons géopolitique de cette
guerre en ukraine avec vous d'abord il
n'y a pas eu de guerre éclair
contrairement à ce qu'espérait vladimir
poutine au fond voilà les patriotes
ukrainiens ont pris les armes et se sont
soudés dans une nation qui existent bel
et bien sûr n'osions la voix c'est déjà
le premier échec vous diriez de poutine
dans cette guerre c'était un échec très
grave c'est une défaite fondamental il a
surestimé les capacités de son armée et
il n'a pas compris qu'il y avait un
patriotisme ukrainiens comme vous le
dites il aurait pourtant dû lire les
chiffres du référendum de 91 qui a donné
l'indépendance à l'ukraine qui a
confirmé l'indépendance de l'ukraine où
il y avait dans tout le pays avec 90 %
des ukrainiens qui ont voté pour
l'indépendance et même dans les
districts de l'est qu'on dit pro russe
qui sont russophones mais pas forcément
pro russe est évidemment cette ce
patriotisme n'était pas anti russe au
départ mais devenu aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui il est évidemment à cause
des actions de la russie vous qui avez
beaucoup écrit qu'au fond de démocratie
était en crise qu'on avait cru naïvement
qu'on l'ait choisie c'est pour tel alors
confond c'était le mur de berlin qui
s'effondrait le bloc soviétique qui
s'effondrait parce qu'on ne voulait plus
de ce système là mais pas pour autant
pour adhérer à nos valeurs c'est
vraiment très présent dans ce dans ce
livre le premier 21e siècle chez
flammarion qu'est ce que vous vous dites
oui c'est secret bien quand même se
battre pour ses valeurs de la démocratie
pour son modèle et regardez l'europe on
se dit qu'au fond elle est pas si malade
caussade notre démocratie j'ai écouté
l'émission que qui vient de se terminer
et je voyais la montée des violences que
vous que vous décriviez je me dis que
nos démocraties sont rentrés malades je
vis aux états unis où le système est
totalement bloquée mais en même temps
c'est vrai que quand on voit à l'ukraine
on voit des citoyens qui redécouvre
l'importance d'avoir des valeurs
communes ce qui est triste c'est qu'il
faille une agression comme celle de la
russie sur l'ukraine pour qu'on retrouve
le sens des valeurs et dans nos pays
nous avons un sentiment naturel de
soutien aux ukrainiens qui est mais en
même temps je voudrais être sûr que si
nous étions nous mêmes plus directement
touché si nos économies devaient
souffrir du soutien à l'ukraine est-ce
que ce fonds unis tiendraient je ne sais
pas penser que le soutien et l'unité
derrière les ukrainiens et et un mur
friable qu'on n'est pas prêt à se priver
ou à faire des sacrifices avec les
conséquences que cette garde peut avoir
va avoir sans doute dans je ne sais pas
ce qu'il est possible que oui mais en
même temps il faut avoir l'honnêteté de
reconnaître que pour le moment nous
sommes les spectateurs de la guerre nous
ne sommes pas dans la guerre et donc il
ya une certaine c'est pas très coûteux
de m un ruban bleu et jaune à la
boutonnière c'est autre chose si on doit
se priver de gaz si on doit faire des
sacrifices pour pour décorer sur
l'instant nos dirigeants n'en prennent
pas le chemin il ya un conseil européen
jeudi et un sommet de l'otan va en
parler je dis aussi tout ça à bruxelles
on va voir la carte parce que pour
l'instant même si les mises en échec
d'une certaine manière parce que au fond
l'armée progresse beaucoup moins vite il
ne cède rien vadimir poutine tout le sud
est autour de la mer d'azov mec est
quasiment sauce au contrôle même si les
villes ne sont pas tombées il faut le il
faut préciser tout de même vous qui avez
de nombreux interlocuteurs j'en suis sûr
autour de ce conflit aujourd'hui que
veut poutine avec cette guerre quel est
son objectif
jusqu'à la veille de la guerre jusqu'au
discours qu'il a prononcé avant la
guerre on pense beaucoup pensaient que
son objectif c'était de revoir les bases
de la sécurité européenne
l'idée c'était que la russie au fou
avait été victime d'une décision qui
avait été prise au moment de sa plus
grande faiblesse il fallait
dans l'otan notamment exactement et là
il y avait la possibilité d'une
négociation mais quand on a entendu son
discours et quand on a vu le lendemain
la manière dont ils voulaient envahir la
totalité de l'ukraine
on a eu l'impression et j'ai toujours
cette impression malheureusement que
l'ambition de poutine est différente il
ya une question identitaire qui
nationalise le nationalisme rule quoi
s'est reconstitué l'urss c'est plutôt
reconstituer l empire russe que l'urss
il a eu des mots très sévères dans son
discours sur lénine c'est une question
d'identité pour lui il n'ya pas de
peuple ukrainien il ya un peuple russe
et un peuple ukrainien qui sont le même
peuple et sur cette base là il est très
difficile d'engager une négociation
qu'on ne peut pas négocier sur une
question d'identité c'est ce que vous
nous dites parce qu'aujourd'hui zelensky
il est prêt à aller assez loin s'il
rencontrait poutine dit il il est prêt à
renoncer au donbass renoncer à son
entrée dans l'otan devenir une sorte de
pays nôtre ça il le dit penser que cette
issue sur cette base là est envisageable
je crois que hélène ce qui fait preuve
d'un très grand courage en montrant
justement qu'il est prêt à la
négociation et à la négociation sur des
sujets sensibles où il n'est pas certain
que tout le peuple ukrainien soit
derrière lui mais je pense quand même
temps plus la guerre dure plus on voit
ces images épouvantables plus les
souffrances des ukrainiens s'accumulent
plus il devient difficile d'avoir cette
négociation froide entre diplomates d'un
côté on peut dire bien sûr
à force de souffrir on va faire dès
qu'on va faire des concessions et les
russes à force de voir qu'ils ne peuvent
pas gagner vont devoir négocier sassine
logique un peu abstraite mais la
dynamique de la guerre pour le moment
n'est pas elle qui va vers la
négociation elle est favorable à poutine
je ne sais pas elle n'est pas favorable
aux négociations et les parigots
situation on va s'habituer mais en tout
cas vous nous prédisait une peyrelongue
je pense plutôt une guerre non je pense
que malheureusement la guerre qui
ressemble le plus à la guerre que nous
voyons aujourd'hui c'est la guerre de
syrie qui a duré des années avec des
souffrances immenses et ça qu'il faut
éviter c'est pour ça que je pense qu'en
même temps que la la possibilité de
négociations et malheureusement
lointaine il faut continuellement garder
la porte de la négociation ouverte alors
en attendant qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya
un sommet de l'otan très important je
dis vous allez sûrement des sources
parmi les polonais qui au vol taper vite
et fort et qui disent il est affaibli
poutine s'est maintenant il faut faire
cette zone d'exclusion aérienne peut
être un pont aérien avec kiev il faut y
aller maintenant
pas sûr qu'il soit entendu vous pensez
que au niveau militaire
les lignes peuvent bouger il ya un vrai
dilemme moral pour tous les goûts des
pays qui ont des valeurs de l'humanité
parce que d'un côté face un peuple
agressé
le sentiment naturelle est de vouloir
lui porter le match nul apporter le
maximum dead
en même temps nous sommes face à un pays
qui a des armes nucléaires et utilisez
vous pour cet aplomb l'enseigné lance
qu'il ya une bonne part de bluff mais en
même temps personne n'a envie de trop
tester ce genre ce genre de bluff et
donc qu'il ya une prudence naturelle
vis-à-vis de la russie sa véritable
raison qui fait qu'on n'intervient pas
exactement c'est à dire face à une
puissance nucléaire personne ne veut ne
veut risquer un affrontement direct avec
la russie avec le risque d' escalade
quand on parle de zone d'exclusion
aérienne
c'est la commissaire ce que ça veut dire
en une façon concrète c'est qu'on abat
des avions russes et donc on est on est
en guerre avec la russie et les
occidentaux sont prêts à aller très loin
je pense pour soutenir l'ukraine mais
pas au point d'être dans l'affrontement
direct avec la russie y compris celles
arme chimique est utilisée par les
d'assyrie de baden a eu ces mots
aujourd'hui les russes assurent que
l'ukraine possède des armes chimiques et
biologiques en ukraine c'est un signe
clair que vladimir poutine envisage
d'utiliser ces deux types d'armes je
crois que si les russes en venait à
utiliser l'armé chimique les sanctions
qui ne sont pas encore prises seraient
prises l'église allemand de la russie
serait totale ce serait quoi l embargo
sur le gaz quelles sanctions ne sont pas
encore prises pour configurer concret
pour les choses le/la sens de la
sanction qui n'est pas encore prise et
les exportations d'énergie et surtout
les exportations de gaz parce que le
pétrole comme c'est un produit fongible
si on arrête d'acheter du pétrole
d'autres pays peuvent l'acheter tandis
que pour le gaz parce qu'il ya des
installations fixes si on arrête
d'acheter du gaz à la russie elle ne
pourra pas le vendre à d'autres et donc
les centaines de millions de dollars que
les russes reçoivent chaque jour à cause
de grâce à leurs exportations ils ne
recevront plus et ça c'est une pression
financière très forte sur sur l'état
russe mais en même temps ça créerait une
crise économique sérieuse en europe
parce qu'on pense simplement qu'on va
avoir moins de chauffage et moines mais
c'est beaucoup plus grave que ça c'est
l'électricité c'est toute l'économie de
nos pays qui est atteinte la chine
voudrait qu'on dise un mot parce que
pour l'instant elle observe neutralité
je dirais ambiguë quel peut être son
rôle dans ce conflit quelles sont ses
intérêts vis-à-vis de l'allié russe je
crois que ce conflit
dérange profondément la chine parce que
la stratégie de la chine c'est une
stratégie comme le disent souvent les
diplomates chinois de gagnant gagnant
c'est de nous enveloppée dans une sorte
d'endormissement ou qui dilue les
conflits où nous sommes tous là dans une
économie globalisée à s'acheter à se
vendre et en évitant tout ce qui peut
faire des différences et un conflit
comme celui du cren c'est exactement
l'opposé de cela alors les chinois sont
d une position à mon sens à mon avis
très embarrassée parce que d'un côté ils
veulent rester bien sûr les partenaires
dans un
partenariat avec la russie ne serait ce
que pour faire face aux états unis et
parce que pour des raisons stratégiques
évidemment c'est important pour mais en
même temps ils ont sans doute très envie
que ce conflit s'arrête parce que plus
le monde se divise avec des lignes
claires plus cette stratégie d'angle de
sofialys comprenant veloppement est
difficile à mener ses passionnantes vous
écoutez je conseille vivement ce livre
le premier 21e siècle chez flammarion
vous l'avez écrit un an
mais il ya beaucoup de choses notamment
chapitre sur la guerre là c'est
carrément prémonitoire parce que vous
étiez de ceux qui pensaient déjà que ce
n'était pas réservé aux livres
d'histoire y compris en europe pour
rester avec nous vous avez accepté de
rester pour la page présidentielle loin
revenir en france jean marie guéhenno
c'est le scan on est à dix neuf jours du
premier tour et on va accueillir nos
chroniqueurs comme chaque soir pour en
parler
mais avant mais il y a les deux bras de
fatalité au grand remplacement et de la
mole vous propose le rose dalmore d'agir
pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travail aux travailleurs le système aux
exclus il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la france sa grandeur
la russie à cela pas de mystère c'est de
vol
nos trois scanner ils sont en place ils
sont en forme géraldine muhlmann
politologue et vous allez nous parler
des affiches et des slogans de campagne
va voir que c'est très important pour
les candidats jean rémi baudot bonsoir
france info télé vous avez parlé de
marine le pen double visage mais on
commence avec l'oeil de blacko stéphane
qu'est ce qui a retenu votre oeil
aujourd'hui alors ce qui me saute elle a
eu ce matin c'est bien sûr le croisement
de la courbe c'est à dire que vous
regardez la fameuse courbe vous allez
voir que la tortue mélenchon comme il se
qualifie lui-même va doucement mais
grimpe sans jamais faire marche arrière
tandis qu'au contraire ceux qui sont
partis comme des lièvres pécresse et
zemmour ne cesse de dégringoler donc
leurs courtes sont croisés et dans
certains sondages jean luc mélenchon et
même à 15% voilà c'est 13 parfois 15 des
bons les chiffres pas super important ce
qui compte nous disent les sondeurs
c'est la dynamique évidemment et donc la
dynamique elle est plutôt évidemment du
côté de mélange regardez c'est comme ce
rassemblement place de la république ce
que les chiffres sont importants est-ce
qu'ils étaient vraiment cent mille temps
j'étais sans doute pas 100 milles mais
il vend la dynamique avec eux d'ailleurs
françois ruffin s'est pas gêné pour
faire un grand cri de la victoire comme
le nantais généralement les vestiaires
de foot là c'était pour remercier les
équipes on écoute
j'ai pas pu bien mon foot made alors
qu'il faut je me rattrape
madame ça s'appelle de la dynamique bon
chez zemmour et pécresse s'est un peu
moins joyeux on imagine oui le prouvent
les mauvais but est tombé sous la barre
des 10% pourtant il comptait beaucoup
sur la nièce de marine le pen qu'il
avait réussi à allier pour axa atteindre
le deuxième tour c'est exactement
l'inversé qui semble se produire une
cesse de dégringoler alors pourquoi
cette chute dans les sondages vous
doutez bien que et une réunion de crise
on a réuni les stratèges et il est
apparu aux yeux de reconquête que le
problème c'est que le programme sur
l'immigration n'est pas du tout assez
ferme dans sont convaincus donc ce qui
est logique c'est qu'il entendait donner
un petit tour de vis supplémentaire sur
l'immigration c'était hier soir on
écoutera eric zemmour ce que je veux si
vous voulez c'est renvoyer tous les gens
dont on ne veux plus je veux un
ministère de la remise gracieuse et de
l'expulsion des étrangers dont on ne
veut plus donc c'était les néologismes
quant à part robin graciant sur son
ordinateur il souligné en rouge c'est un
mot qui qui vient d'inventer pour donc
essayer de gagner encore quelques poils
il ya très peu de chances d'être au
second tour iata un sondage qui lui
donne un peu d'espoir un sondage de 2002
fait qu'ils sont dès ce 22 mars 2002
voyait à l'époque le pen était à 9% et
un mois plus tard il était au second
tour donc bah voilà nous aimons rien de
son trou de souris et lui valérie
pécresse elle a aussi un coup à jouer
rien n'est joué pour elle ou pas alors
bon pour être honnête je sais pas qui
boudent pécresse ici mais ça serait
quand même une sacrée surprise qu'elle
soit au second tour mais justement c'est
ça le secret de valérie pécresse sait
que plus la victoire s'éloignent plus
elle a le sentiment qu'elle va gagner
alors je sais ça me paraît un peu
contradictoire mais en fait c'est parce
qu'elle a souvent été donnée perdante
par élections auxquelles séparé se
présentait donc étonné si je suis donnée
perdante c'est très bon signe en écoute
moi je vous dis que je serai là surprise
du second tour savez j'étais là surprise
toute ma vie j'ai été la surprise aux
régionales j'ai été là sionisme la
surprise la surprise à la primaire de la
droite je suis là une femme qui est
tenace déterminer qui va jusqu'au bout
et que à un moment donné celui qui gagne
c'est celui qui croît jusqu'à la
dernière minute quand on est croix dans
son camp à la surprise de dernière
minute bah ouais les moyens moyens quoi
c'est sûr que là par valérie pécresse
qui croient encore en tout cas guillaume
larrivé lui il envisage des défaites en
dix ans avant toute façon même si on
perd luc notre programme c'est
exactement le même que macron c'est pas
grave on fera une majorité d'entre eux
imaginent la tête de la pauvre valérie
pécresse qui crient au vol depuis
plusieurs semaines macron m'a volé mon
programme macron de volée manquera et
maintenant il ya un autre vol qui est en
train de se passer c'est cadeau macron
est en train de le voler sa victoire
incroyable leur écoute
mais thématique il faut que je les
imposants ces trois dernières semaines
et que je dise ça ne vous laissez pas
voler ses fonctions comme en 2010 elle a
trop tard ne vous laissez pas voler
cette élection alors bon malgré tout sur
ça un petit peu même si elle dans une
position un peu désespéré à dire
attention aux vols de l'élection ça
rappelle quand même les trompes piste
avec le slogan devant le capitole
c'était stop de sting de cire ne volait
pas l'élection donc peut-être d'autres
arguments pour les riz pécresse a
employé j'imagine
oui c'est très inquiétant la
délégitimation des élections c'est quand
même un des fondements de la démocratie
et si on commence dès avant l'élection a
sapé la confiance des électeurs dans
l'élection on a ce qui s'est passé après
les etats-unis ont à ce qui est en vous
et en devoirs une certaine influence
trump heist en france non parce que je
crois malheureusement que le phénomène
en face que j'explique dans mon livre et
est beaucoup plus fondamental que les
circonstances particulières de la france
les états unis à une crise des partis
politiques qui est qu'on voit aux états
unis avec la manière dans le parti
républicain a évolué et je pense que en
plus des partis politiques
eric zemmour sociaux de saumon très
proche de trump marine le pen essaie de
le rencontrer a raté zemmour je crois un
petit coup de fil avec l'imec du
président donc ce cas d'un modèle pour
une partie de ses secrets
normalement on va passer au scanner
marine le pen avec vous ce soir jean
régnier boîte au double visage multiples
visages vous nous dites elle est donné
en deuxième position entre 18 et 20%
selon les instituts en fait il ya un
point qui m'a interpellé ces dernières
semaines dans tous les états majors tous
vous dise marine le pen fait une bonne
campagne c'est un discours qu'il faut
écouter qu'un évidemment mes
interlocuteurs à ce moment là ce sont
chez les verts au ps à la république en
marche ceux qui ne veulent pas qu'elle
gagne et pourtant ils font ce constat et
ça m'a amené à me poser une question
quelle est la marine le pen qu'on voit
devant nous car souvenez-vous la
campagne de 2017 on la disait pas à ces
travailleuses mal an ray approximative
sur les chiffres elle ne connaissait pas
ses dossiers aujourd'hui elle fait une
toute autre campagne ou peut-être plus
tôt elle montre un autre visage qu'à ce
qui s'est passé depuis 2007 est bien de
ses proches m'explique elle s'est
libérée libéré du poids du parti elle a
moins de comptes à rendre à la toile
était son programme sur l'europe l'euro
la double nationalité elle est libérée
de son nom aussi désormais c'est
uniquement marine c'est comme ça que
cyril hanouna par exemple l'appel tout
le temps en plateau on se souvient de
ses photos avec les chiens elle joue de
ces fous rires sur les plateaux des
émissions de divertissement en fait elle
fait une campagne à bas bruit sur le
terrain sur les marchés proches des gens
c'est quelqu'un d'accessible c'est une
bonne copine théorise l'un de ses
conseillers oui mais tout ça c'est de la
forme car sur le fond elle a surtout
réussi à gommer à toutes les petites
aspérités elle a fait oublier son nom
son passé politique jusqu'à même
l'héritage idéologique est de son parti
un tour de force qui lui réussit songez
que depuis le début de la campagne
marine le pen n'a eu aucun ralliement
elle n'a eu que des défections et
pourtant rien ne semble enrayer sa
dynamique alors comment on explique ça
justement et bien ses amis vous disent
qu'elle a beaucoup travaillé c'est
possible c'est certainement possible
mais je pense qu'il ya deux phénomènes
qui se croisent et en fait
s'additionnent d'abord évidemment elle
récolte les fruits de la fameuse
dédiabolisation du fn ensuite elle joue
la carte de l'humanisation elle a
rajouté du social dans le programme du
fn elle a délaissé les thématiques les
plus brutales de l'extrême droite au
profit d'un discours plus doux plus
nyons et sur le pouvoir d'achat sur les
femmes avec ça elle gagne en crédibilité
elle fait moins peur pour autant elle
n'a pas renier en fait les piliers
historiques de l'extrême droite
l'immigration la sécurité ça ça reste
son adn même sa posture républicaine sur
la laïcité c'est avant tout une critique
de l'islam sur le fond en fait elle n'a
pas beaucoup changé la chance qu'elle a
c'est que on en parlait à l'instant eric
zemmour est tellement plus brutale qui
la replace mécaniquement au centre alors
dans les prochaines semaines en vue du
premier tour elle devrait continuer à la
cuve il est cultivé cette cette posture
apaisé moins brouillonne mais est-ce
qu'elle pourra la tenir dans un éventuel
second tour car parfois le naturel
revient au galop avec des fautes de
carre incompréhensible ça fait une
semaine qu'elle raconte partout avec une
histoire d'une infirmière qui des pères
qui dépenseraient 3 2 200 euros 250
euros je reprend l'histoire d'une
infirmière qui payerait 250 euros de
carburant par jour en réalité ces 250 km
qu'elle fait par jour et ça coûte 38
euros d'essence c'est le genre
d'approximations elle pourrait payer
cash en cas de nouveaux débats avec
emmanuel macron elle est allée recentrer
par zemmour mais attention aux
apparences où il rentrait enfin moi ce
qui m'inquiète c'est de voir que entre
les deux candidats de l'extrême droite
ça fait une feinte pourcentage quand
même et la 30 % à 30 % c'est sa classe
et inédit en france ça n'a jamais été un
socle aussi haut on verra d'ailleurs
c'est pas seulement les gens d'extrême
droite ils votent pour le pen sont des
jeunes et les classes populaires donc
c'est des gens qui les classe population
pas forcément des gens qui sont
alliés aux idées simplement se plaignent
du pouvoir d'achat du fait qu' il en
semble plus juste les élites les oublie
donc ça c'est peut-être un truc qui
existent en france ça c'est la crise des
partis politiques dits de gouvernement
c'est ça qui est très grave on peut
commémorer qu'elle a perdu toutes les
élections intermédiaires etc originale
elle n'a pas eu tout ce qu'elle avait
promis de l'offrir
pouvait capitaliser d'ici le premier
tour et surtout si elle est qualifiée ce
qui se passera entre entrées d'eau tour
ce serait très intéressant alors
s'adresser au plus grand nombre vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
l'objectif d'une affiche de campagne
géraldine muhlmann vous avez regardé
c'est un enjeu crucial pour les
candidats même si on n'est pas forcément
certains d'un dut l'impact de l'impact
est ce que toutes saisons en tout cas
pour eux c'est très important au point
qu'ils ont changé leurs affiches pour le
dernier mois de campagne alors les
nouvelles affiches on peut les analyser
comme ça moi je vous propose une grille
d analyse qui m'a intéressé il ya le
regard sur la photo et il y a le second
alors pour ce qui est du regard vous
avez des candidats qui regardent le
spectateur dans les yeux il est il se
place dans un certain présent le présent
du spectateur comme pour lier tu vois je
suis là je suis décontracté je suis
déterminé je suis présidentiable
maintenant et puis vous avez donc pour
ce
plat ni vernis d'algos elle vous regarde
avec sourire ensuite carrousel un peu
man 3 dans les yeux que mannequin quand
même roussel pourquoi pas
mais garde vous avez dupont aignan vous
regarde bien aussi aimé regarder le
regard et s'était tapé droit plus voilà
le pen à la pression de la résolution
numéro nous les beaux-arts macron alors
macro évidemment en plus il peut être je
suis présidentielle est présidentiable
je suis au présent je suis évidemment
celui qui est là et qui comptent y
rester pierre vous avez le regard au
loin le regard vers l'avenir le regard
qui dit le futur qui dit le changement
ça c'est un autre choix jadot oui tout
de suite on voit la différence mélenchon
oui
et ça donne autre choc donc les deux
options existent et il faut choisir de
hollow présent ouvert là on voit bien la
distinction 1 selon la distance porté
par le regard ça c'est les images les
mots le slogan est bien envie de faire
la même analyse vous avez des slogans
d'un côté qui évoque d'anglais venir le
projet donc en quelque sorte le regard à
nouveau vers le lointain le changement
hidalgo ensemble changeons à venir
dupont-aignan
choisir la liberté est à l'avant vous
avez aussi roussel la france des jours
heureux on voit bien que c'est vers le
haut
et zemmour qui a repris le slogan d'eric
ciotti pendant la primaire pour que la
france reste la france reste un projet
pour demain mélenchon est aussi un autre
monde est possible et puis vous avez des
slogans je dirais différents qui parle
du présent qui qualifie la situation
d'urgence ce que je pense moi le
candidat que nous sommes ensemble
maintenant c'est presque comme si les je
suis déjà président tu vois regardez
regardez les slogans jadot faire face
maintenant vous avez le pen marine
présidente andrée que c'est fait la
france qu'on aime oui c'est un rapport
au présent pécresse aussi le courage de
faire
maintenant on sent bien le présent macro
évidemment qui non seulement avait le
regard au présent mais ça c'est comme
mme pécresse et le slogan au présent
launay emmanuel macron avec vous alors
voilà ce qui était intéressant et
passionnant qu'est ce qui se passe si on
croise les deux mots le regard et le
slogan catégories logiques ya ya les
regards et les lectures
le regard vers le à présent vers
l'avenir hidalgo dupont aignan zemmour
regard vers le présent slogan vers
l'avenir vous avez ensuite les regards
vers l'avenir le slogan sur le présent
jadot le tout le seul à avoir choisi
cette configuration les avenirs à venir
ce sont ceux qui regardent vers le
lointain et qui ont aussi un slogan sur
le changement dans le futur et ça c'est
mélenchon mélenchon tout seul rapidement
puis enfin le présent présent ce qui
vous regarde maintenant et qui vous
parle du présent c'est macron c'est
pécresse et c'est le pen bon en very
conclusions restent dans le futur ça
compte pour tout le monde après ils font
des choix plus ou moins radicaux je
pense que les communicants passe par là
aussi et je suis un peu de votre avis
myriam en fait je ne suis pas sûr ça
content que ça bon
merci merci à vous merci jean marie
guéhenno le premier 21e siècle c'est à
mario je le recommande vivement merci
les scanner tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire excellent film pour cette
journée mondiale de l'eau il est signé
jérôme free tellement basse sur l'eau
quant à moi je vous dis à demain
[Musique]